pop et du tour de france a repris ses
droits dans les alpes bruit puis froid
et brouillard victoire et maillot jaune
pour l'italien pantani une sérieuse
défaillances pour l'allemand jan ullrich
ne dirige pas directeur sportif et le
médecin de l'équipe hollandaise tvm
transféré à reims juge d'instruction
pourraient les mettre en examen ce soir
jacques toubon abandonne après quatre
mois de querelles avec le maire de paris
jean tiberi il a décidé aujourd'hui de
dissoudre son groupe d'opposants au sein
du conseil municipal au maire
chirurgicale mondiale a bordeaux une
artère aorte remplacé par une prothèse
au moyen de la vidéochirurgie ce qui
évite une opération traditionnels les
vacances des autres ce soir les
américains qui par rapport à nous freine
très peu de vacances et pas toujours en
couple et puis les italiens qui
préfèrent l'hôtel aux locations et dont
les deux stations préférées sont rimini
et portofino madame monsieur bonsoir les
affaires de dopage ont connu d'autres
développements aujourd'hui nous y
reviendrons dans un instant mais ne
boudons pas notre plaisir la compétition
a repris ses droits aujourd'hui sur le
tour de france cycliste avec une étape
alpestre digne de la légende du tour la
pluie le froid le drame la joie avec la
victoire d'étape et le maillot jaune
pour l'italien pantani qui a relégué à
plus de cinq minutes l'allemand jan
ullrich et à plus d'un quart d'heure le
français laurent jalabert résumé florent
gautreau alain points c'est le sommet du
tour où le riche est au plus bas jamais
le visage de l'allemande avait trahi une
telle souffrance
le dernier vainqueur du tour a craqué
sous les coups de boutoir de ses
adversaires première salve avec rinero
au deuxième plan le coéquipier de zhu
lieke deuxième au général dans le col du
télégraphe la révélation française du
tour 98 fait exploser le peloton
c'est un peu fatigué ce matin mais bon
il reste plus qu'une semaine alors
j'étais motivé là j'ai vu que j'étais
5ème au général alors bobby et 2e des
coureurs 0,8 dans des conditions
apocalyptiques brouillard dont le
telegraph neige fondue dans le galibier
pluie et froid aux deux halles le tour
s'enrhume mais il en faut plus pour
décourager luc leblanc qui part dans une
chevauchée fantastique et solitaire
derrière les hommes de tête
à cet instant oulrich contrôler les
favoris se surveille mes pantani a
choisi ce sera ici dans l'ascension du
galibier à 50 km de l'arrivée qu'il
portera son attaque
l'italien l'avait dit ce matin dans la
montagne
seul reste l'homme et son courage son
courage et grands son talent est immense
et puis c'est la descente en enfer
la descente aux impairs leblanc
s'habille en roulant difficilement
pantani préfère s'arrêter
c'est risqué djukic empêtré dans son
k-way quitte la route
il a eu chaud d'autres ont eu très froid
hier j'étais tellement frigorifié que je
l'aï même pas même à décembre dégâts
libyen et là je compte si je louche et
riche père son maillot jaune avant la
montée vers les deux halles il crève et
il craque
joe lynch en profite pour attaquer
l'américain va garder sa deuxième place
au général
mais le héros c'est l'éléphant timo
pantani réalise un exploit en reléguant
hollerich à 8 minutes et 57 secondes où
le riche des faits franchi la ligne très
loin des premiers au général l'allemand
est quatrième à presque 6 minutes et
pantani veut devenir le premier italien
depuis m'ont dit à gagner le tour de
france
nous reviendrons tout à l'heure sur
l'ambiance aujourd'hui dans cette étape
de montagne mais dans la sphère du
dopage au tour de l'équipe hollandaise
tvm le directeur sportif et le médecin
ont été transférés aujourd'hui à reims
le juge chargé de l'enquêté les
interrogent depuis le début de
l'après-midi pour éventuellement les
mettre en examen dès ce soir une affaire
a priori similaire à celle de l'équipe
festina à la différence près que ce
n'est pas l'avis du substitut du
procureur de reims olivier galzi
jean-pierre past 16 heures le convoi
arrive enfin en palais de justice de
reims
dans la première voiture en jaune le
médecin de tvm derrière lui en bleu
le directeur sportif les deux hommes ont
rendez vous pour parler dopage avec le
juge d'instruction
odile madrolle dans son bureau du 1er
étage ces questions sont prêtes
elle entendra les deux hommes un par un
si ce prix m l'air pensif devra répondre
était-il informé du transport de péaule
intercepté en mars dernier à qui étaient
destinés ces produits dans l'ombre du
directeur le médecin devra lui aussi
s'expliquer sur les produits
pensez-y dans sa chambre d'hôtel jeudi
dernier devant le palais de justice la
masse des journalistes à temps car ces
auditions pourraient bien décider du
sort de l'équipe tv m dans la course
même si le substitut du procureur
explique que les produits dopants
retrouver ici ne concerne pas pour
l'heure les coureurs tout ce que l'on
peut savoir c'est que le médecin de
l'équipe en avait à sa disposition
là sur ce point il appartiendra au
magistrat instructeur de déterminer si
oui ou non les coureurs ou pu avoir
recours à ce type de produits d'une
façon consciente ou éventuellement d'une
façon inconsciente mais en l'état
nous n'avons au niveau 2 rens à la
différence de festina qu'une détention
de produits anabolisants par deux bancs
dossiers légaux heures ne sont pas mises
en cause
c'est pour ça que festina n'est pas tvm
et tvm n'est pas festina
mais tout dépendra de ce qui se dira
dans les heures qui viennent derrière
ses fenêtres des éventuels confession
que pourrait recueillir le juge
odile madrolle sur place à reims
olivier galzi les deux dirigeants livier
de tvm sont toujours en cours
d'interrogatoire
oui absolument daniel 6 priem le
directeur sportif et andrei michailof le
médecin sont à l'heure où je vous parle
toujours entendus dans le bureau du juge
cela fait déjà quatre heures maintenant
on ne sait pas combien de temps cela va
durer
mais ce que l'on sait de source proche
del'enquête l'enquète c'est que cela
devrait déboucher sur une mise en examen
inéluctable pour les deux hommes
peut-être peut-être assortis d'un mandat
de dépôt c'est-à-dire qu'il passerait la
nuit en prison ici à reims on vient
d'écouter le substitut du procureur de
république de reims qui ne veux pas
comparer les deux affaires
tvm et festina on peut penser que
richard virenque et ses coéquipiers
estime qu'il y aura là
si c'était le cas deux poids deux
mesures oui effectivement on peut
s'imaginer ce soir richard virenque et
ses coéquipiers comme vous le dites
entendre la déclaration du substitut du
procureur et être particulièrement
surpris ils ont été ils ont eu une garde
à vue très sévère la société du tour de
france a été aussi assez sévère avec eux
et ce soir on peut s'imaginer
effectivement qu'ils pensent qu'il
pourrait y avoir deux poids deux mesures
merci olivier si vous aviez des
informations on retourne à reims bien
entendu
direction maintenant de maître collard
l'avocat justement de richard virenque
qui je vous le rappelle a toujours
contesté le fait de s'être dopé
contrairement à certains de ses
coéquipiers
maître collard qui ne comprendraient pas
que l'on puisse envisager de traiter
différemment
l'équipe tv m de l'équipe festina maître
collard l'équipe festina et exclu du
tour les coureurs sont placés en garde à
vue
interrogé dans les conditions légales
mais dur pour les mêmes faits les
coureurs de l'équipe tv m ne sont pas
placés en garde à vue ne sont pas
interrogées et continue à courir deux
poids deux mesures ça n'est pas juste
et selon nos informations deux anciens
coureurs de l'équipe festina emmanuel
magnien et gilles bouvart ont été
entendus aujourd'hui par les policiers
du srpj de lille viennent d'être placés
en garde à vue
ces nouveaux développements dans la
sphère tv aimons bien entendu un
retentissement sur le tour même si les
coureurs ont décidé pour se protéger en
quelque sorte de ne plus parler de ces
problèmes
ils n'ont pas pour autant disparu comme
par enchantement et la menace plane
toujours donc sur l'équipe hollandaise
tvm qui si elle était convaincue de
dopage pourrait être exclu du tour
reportage nathalie moisan discrétion de
rigueur à l'hôtel de tvm ce soir ni les
coureurs ni l'encadrement technique ne
se montrent très bavard al'approche des
rats microbes présents la journée a été
dure pour toute l'équipe toujours à
l'arrière de la course
seuls deux coureurs accepteront de
répondre à la télévision hollandaise des
coureurs plutôt rassurés d'apprendre que
leurs directeurs sportifs et leurs
soigneurs n'ont pas été mis en examen
satisfait que le tour de france continue
pour eux aussi
de son côté monsieur 24 heures le
représentant de la direction n'a pas
souhaité nous parler comme si de rien
était ce soir les mécaniciens de
l'équipe ont repris leur travail
d'entretien des vélos là encore le
silence tient lieu de réaction je n'ai
pas de réaction
je n'ai aucun commentaire à faire
l'avenir de l'équipe est suspendu aux
décisions judiciaires chacun est dans la
tente à proximité des camions des
touristes hollandais n'exprime guerre de
compassion pour leurs équipes qui vous
avez trouvé de l'opéra ou d'autres
drogues dans les chambres de tvm
je pense qu'ils doivent être suspendues
comme les festina je pense même qu'ils
sont coupables on a pas de paix ou dans
sa chambre quand on en prend pas cette
culpabilité des coureurs l'enquêté en
cours n'a jamais apporté la preuve
l'équipe tv m se retranche ce soir
derrière cette seule certitude et feint
de se concentrer sur la crosse sur la
course uniquement sur place pascal douce
est bon à l'arrivée d'étape alors pascal
avec cette magnifique étape de montagne
d'aujourd'hui est ce que le sujet dopage
a complètement disparu des conversations
un petit peu oui parce qu'effectivement
comme vous le dites l'étape était
magnifique tout le monde ici ne parle
que de l'exploit de marco pantani et
l'ambiance n'était pas vraiment aux
confidences comme vous pouvez le voir il
pleut les coureurs à l'arrivée ici était
transie il avait plus tôt at the se
réfugier dans leur hôtel ou dans leur
car est évidemment le mot d'ordre est
dictée par les coureurs il ya trois
jours est largement suivi personne n'a
envie de parler de dopage cela dit
lorsque nous rencontrions des acteurs du
tour des directeurs sportifs entre
autres il nous demandait
systématiquement des nouvelles de ce qui
se passait à reims la sphère tvm et dans
les esprits même si elle n'est pas
omniprésente
merci pascal pour cette atmosphère que
vous nous transmettez donc de la ville
étape pour en revenir à l'étape
justement aujourd'hui dans les alpes
courue sous la pluie dans le froid et le
brouillard les journalistes spécialisés
dans le cyclisme et qui aime les
superlatifs ne manqueront pas d'en
employer dantesque légendaire courageux
et passionné le public qui s'était lui
aussi massés sur le bord des routes
alexandre kara et nathalie gal
aujourd'hui sur le tour de france les
spectateurs avaient un style ganao la
collection était 98
arrivé cette année la tendance et
coloris bien adapté aux conditions météo
+ 9 2 et dans la brume et c'est vrai ça
vaut le coup d'oeil
il ya les classiques parapluie k way et
gros chien de rigueur mais aussi les
avant gardistes sacs poubelles
déstructuré et casquettes bariolés en
résumé vous l'aurez compris pour être
sur la route du tour il fallait vraiment
aimé ça et pour profiter de la pluie non
seulement il fallait se lever tôt mais
en plus venir de loin on a constaté de
tentes pour sauver la vie donc c'est
installé dedans me manger ça pleut
maintenant on attend c'est bon mais
aujourd'hui c'est comment bruxelles où
j'attendais l'arrivée du tour de france
et je suis ici déjà deux jours pour
l'égaler c'est le temps qui qui n'est
pas bon en 24 heures la température du
tour a perdu 23 degrés mais pas un
spectateur pour encourager denis
galériens de la montagne ils étaient des
milliers cet après midi dans le froid et
le mauvais temps qu'il leur fallait donc
du courage
tous derrière et les coureurs devant
les obsèques de deux des trois scouts
morts en mer la semaine dernière ont
bien lieu demain matin à mantes-la-jolie
12 et est originaire mais à la demande
de leurs parents mais la demande de
leurs parents plus exactement a été
refusé l'abbé cottard responsable du
camp scout actuellement incarcérés ne
sera pas libéré pour cette occasion
ainsi en a décidé le procureur public de
guingamp reportages et avec des pierres
virginie fiche et olivier sion ces
sommes sont les pères de deux des quatre
scouts mort jeudi dernier au large de la
bretagne
cet après midi ils sont venus demander
au juge en charge de la faire que le
perco tard célèbre la messe
d'enterrement de leurs enfants
le juge refuse finalement de les
recevoir le perco tard prêtres
traditionalistes et responsable du
groupe de scouts restera pour le moment
en prison
à la grande déception des parts j'ai
besoin de médecins de larmes que le
monsieur l'abbé cottard
c'est un homme d'église c'est un père
pour nos enfants c'est un père pour nous
est ce qu'on peut nous refuser le de
voir son père à ses côtés
l'ours on enterre ses enfants mais
l'abbé cottard est directement mise en
cause par la mère de guillaume castanet
ce plaisancier de 31 ans a sauvé trois
scouts des eaux froides de la manche
avant de périr
la mère de guillaume accepte de
témoigner mais en mémoire de son fils
unique
elle ne veut pas apparaître à la camair
ce curé est vraiment un double
responsabilité est celle de l'amour des
enfants et celle de la mort de mon fils
ne peut pas trouver d'excusés à
quelqu'un qui est responsable d'enfants
qui responsable de la vie d'enfants
jédir sont ils n'étaient pas équipés
pour faire du bateau il n'était pas
autorisé à faire des bateaux ils vont
faire une première croisière il ya deux
bateaux qui ont du mal
il oblige encore les enfants à repartir
l'épiscopat français demandent par
ailleurs que l'association des scouts et
guides catholiques prenne ses
responsabilités face à ce drame turquie
nous a tous créés nous rappelle tous au
jour de notre mort bien sûr
mais ça ne veut pas dire que c'est lui
qui est cause de notre mort ou du cause
d'un accident dans une affaire comme
celle de perros guirec
il y a des responsabilités que
l'administration de la jeunesse et des
sports a le droit de rappeler et que la
justice a le droit de sanctionner
demain la messe d'enterrement de deux
des quatre scouts aura lieu à mantes la
jolie
une messe traditionalistes célébrée en
latin neuf jours par 60 mètres de fond
le jeune mineur autrichien coincé à la
suite d'un effondrement dans la mine est
sorti finalement vivent aujourd'hui
apparemment pas trop sérieusement blessé
malheureusement une équipe d'une dizaine
de sauveteurs partis à sa recherche et
toujours elle porté disparu sur place
olivier l'herne une route défoncée et
derrière ces buissons un trou un cratère
et plusieurs maisons qu'il faudra
détruire avant qu'elle ne s'affaisse
complètement
voilà dix jours qu'elles sont là les
foreuses à la recherche d'un bruit d'un
geste de vie dix hommes sont sous c'est
peut-être une ou deux éboulements
successifs les on peut être condamné
hier soir george wein seul prisonnier à
60 mètres de fond pendant neuf jours est
réapparu vivants en bonne santé
apparemment même si sa main tremblait
beaucoup
c'est l'humidité ambiante qui l'a
maintenu en vie mais le bonheur de le
revoir en chair et en os ne masque pas
le malheur annoncé pour les secouristes
prise au piège de cette maudite mines la
polémique bat son plein c'est devenu une
affaire d'état secours désorganisés
foreuse inadaptée coordination on plie
gendarmes sauveteurs totalement
inexistante conférence de presse peu
convaincante pour les amis des
sauveteurs au café juste en face c'est
la consternation
moi je connais tout le monde ne disent
qu'ils sont ensevelies ce sont tous des
collègues
c'est comme un crime les sauveteurs ont
commis des erreurs incroyables des
arguments partagés certains disent
qu'ils sont trois ou quatre encore en
vie mais c'est plus par superstition
qu'autre chose qui peut résister dix
jours sous terre sans manger ni boire
le jeune mineur autrichien miraculé on
peut le dire mais c'est pas encore que
les dix sauveteurs partis à sa recherche
sont à leur tour porté disparu les
fouilles sont loin d'être terminées mais
ici il n'ya plus beaucoup d'espoir de
les voir remonter vivants à la surface
nous prions a vu l'exacte chirac rend
des visites aujourd'hui aux pilotes de
canadair chargé de la lutte contre les
feux de forêt à leur base de brignoles
dans le var le jour même où un accord
était intervenu pour mettre fin à une
grève qui durait depuis les couleurs
semaine
en est qui n'avait pas empêché mais
kadri de fonctionner normalement on chef
de l'état qui a demandé à la justice de
sanctionner très sévèrement les
pyromanes qui met en péril notre
environnement
c'est à dire at il dit l'avenir de
l'humanité
les hommes de la sécurité civile sapeurs
pompiers pilotes de canadair ou encore
de bombardier d'eau connaissent en ce
moment leur plus forte période
d'activité ou plutôt moins de veine
reportage yannick a aussi leur métier
guetteurs de feu ici pour les calanques
il est déjà trop tard mais chaque après
midi l'hélicoptère aigles verts a prêté
par l'entente interdépartementale pour
la protection de la forêt vient apporter
sa petite contribution à la longue
chaîne de la prévention
on est un moyen complémentaire qui
permet de se déplacer dans des jeeps aux
villes telles que forcé eon père me dire
le permet car deux mondes positionner
dans des secteurs relativement facile
d'accuser un autre moyen
voici la tour de contrôle des bouches du
rhône depuis la vigie du grand poète
daniel bellizone y règne en maître sur
le réseau d'observateurs du département
alors voilà rien à cirer
par contre extension sur leurs droits
30 vies j'y ai une cinquantaine de
patrouilles sans relâche tous les jours
les forestiers sapeurs parmi d'autres
sillonnent les massifs car en matière d'
incendies la rapidité d' alerte et donc
d'actions sont primordiales notre
objectif c'est de faire en sorte que
nous réduisions les délais
d'intervention des moyens préventifs ou
des centres secours prépositionnés sur
le terrain de façon à ce que les feux ne
prennent pas de l'importance mirande
regard de l'importance des mires module
d'intervention rapide près 10
positionner sur le terrain pour être
plus efficace plus vite
23 groupe occupe chaque jour cette forêt
méditerranéenne avec un objectif la
préserver au maximum
chez nous sommes en période de tour de
france cycliste on peut dire que jacques
toubon a abandonné aujourd'hui abandonné
sa guerre contre le maire de paris jean
tiberi commencer souvenez vous au mois
d'avril dernier il a décidé en effet de
dissoudre le groupe dissident de la
majorité qu'il avait mis sur pied au
sein de l'hôtel de ville
le président du rpr philippe seguin y
avait fixé un ultimatum qui expirait
dans 48 heures seulement françoise david
jacques gérard petit sourire en coin
pour jacques toubon
il ne sera pas exclue du rpr même si
pour cela il a dû saborder aujourd'hui
le groupe qu'il avait constituée à la
mairie de paris pour s'opposer à jean
tiberi lui-même et ceux du rpr qui
l'avait suivi siégeront à nouveau sur
les bancs de la majorité municipale
nous voulons ainsi levé l'hypothèque de
la division de notre mouvement lui
marquer notre attachement et notre
loyauté et contribuer à l'organisation
de l'opposition nationale que jacques
chirac a appelé de ses voeux le 14
juillet large très large sourire quand
jean tiberi le retour au bercail de
jacques toubon sonne pour lui comme une
victoire
le maire de paris a vécu des moments
très difficiles il n'accorde nine refuse
pardon il préfère dit-il se tourner avec
sérénité vers l'avenir jamais le passé
mais ce qu'il faut maintenant c'est
penser au présent et à l'avenir c'est à
dire travailler pour appliquer nos
engagements 95 et si possible ensemble
écouter les suggestions les propositions
pour améliorer ce travail en commun
c'est le 6 avril dernier que le séisme
s'était abattue sur l'hôtel de ville ce
jour là jacques toubon une trentaine de
conseillers municipaux rpr et udf
dénoncé avec fracas la gestion
municipale et le climat des affaires une
véritable déclaration de guerre
jean tiberi lui qualifiait aussitôt les
dissidents de putschiste
mais dans ce conflit ouvert le maire de
paris avait un allié de poids
son prédécesseur jacques chirac le chef
de l'état avait visiblement pris son
parti ne manquant pas une occasion de le
faire voir jacques toubon a dû céder
revient chirurgicale mondial aujourd'hui
à bordeaux
deux chirurgiens ont remplacé une artère
aorte déficiente par une prothèse en
utilisant la technique de la
microchirurgie assisté par la vidéo sans
ouvrir 100 opérations traditionnelles
reportage
éric perrin philippe dumas c'est un
grand jour pour ces deux chirurgiens de
bordeaux un grand jour pour ce patient
de 65 ans qui va sortir de la clinique
du tondu la vie jours seulement après
son opération
cet homme risque et l'amputation des
deux jambes à cause d'un problème dans
l'artère aorte si le remplacement de
l'artère défectueuses par une prothèse
est couramment pratiqué la technique
utilisée elle est une première grâce à
la coelioscopie pas besoin d'ouvrir le
vendre sur 30 cm quelques petits trous
suffisent une technique moins
traumatisant
c'est l'absence de cicatrices abdominale
malade peut se lever dès le lendemain à
voir reprendre une alimentation et je
crois que ça c'est d'un réel bénéfice
est peut-être écourtée l'hospitalisation
si la coelioscopie
c'est l'utilisation de cette mini caméra
reliée à un écran vidéo qui permet
d'effectuer de la microchirurgie mais
l'opération réalisée ici est également
une première de par la voie d'accès
utilisées généralement on est obligé de
traverser les viscères avec tous les
risques que cela comporte
nous avons choisi de réaliser une voie
d'accès extra plat à savoir soulever
l'ensemble d'émissaires dans leur sac et
aborder ce vaisseau très délicatement en
insufflant le gaz carbonique
ils nous aident à repousser l'ensemble
des dix ers et réalisé la l'implantation
d'un tube de remplacement positionner
latéralement sur l'aorte et qui va
revascularisés apporter du sang artériel
au niveau des membres inférieurs
c'était un rêve aujourd'hui c'est une
réalité
faut dire que c'est une alternative nous
avons là 24 bien précis particulier on
ne peut pas l'appliquer absolument un
tollé qualifié de l'aorte et de ses
branches mais nous avons montré que
c'est et réalise le docteur de l'udc
avait déjà réalisé en 94 à l'hôpital
bagatelle le premier pontage artériel
par coelioscopie
grâce à ces chirurgiens la france est le
pays en pointe dans cette technique où
le patient a tout à gagner
nous sommes le 27 juillet la date de la
rentrée des classes pour un certain
nombre de grands magasins et oui qui
présente déjà les fournitures et les
vêtements qui habilleront vos enfants à
l'automne le moyen pour les mères de
famille de ne pas être pris dans la
foule du mois de septembre est un moyen
pour les commerçants d'étaler leurs
ventes pour noël pourra tout de même
attendre un tout petit peu éric astié
bruno l'hiver tout repos c'est pas de
son âge mais pourtant il fait sa rentrée
au milieu de l'été étrange
la rentrée scolaire a déjà débuté dans
les grandes surfaces c'est l'affluence
les premiers articles ont été disposés
ce week end pour les parents comme pour
les enfants un impératif majeur éviter
le rush de septembre les rayons fou
calme on peut voir facilement c'est
agréable de choisir à ce moment là les
enfants sont contents ça plaide préparer
déjà la rentrée nous éloigner commencer
à la rentrée ses parents venant pour
vous le monde on peut pas choisir pour
commence aujourd'hui on a l'intention de
terminer parce que vraiment c'est
l'horreur
les rentrées scolaires ça devrait pas
exister ces choses là parmi les
nouveautés on attendait des classeurs
avec les pieds zidane ou la tête de
jacques et manqué quinze jours après la
finale de la coupe du monde pas de
footballeur dans les linéaires les
classeurs reste très classique
en revanche cette année les feuilles de
papier se sont agrandies le traditionnel
format a4 est en voie de disparition
mais la vraie nouveauté se trouve au
rayon cartable plus léger plus
confortable pour l'élève tellement mieux
qu'on nous en fait l'article 1
cette année les produits tendances les
cinq filles le faire table à roulettes
le nec plus ultra portable ait moins
d'un kilo super league l'an dernier sont
dix mille articles de fournitures
scolaires ont été achetées le jour de la
rentrée
la moitié des ventes de ses magasins se
réalise sur deux mois faire sa rentrée
en juillet n'est peut-être pas une si
étrange idée
lightweight et internationales dans la
province yougoslave du kosovo les forces
serbes qui ont repris l'offensive ont
visiblement gagner puisqu'ils ont
annoncé ce soir qu'ils avaient qu'elle
avait repris le contrôle de la
principale route qui relie les deux
grandes villes de la province
maryse bien ces combattantes une mission
reprendre au plus vite sur le contrôle
des principaux axes routiers du kosovo
ils sont serbes
ils poursuivent depuis vendredi l'une de
leur plus grande offensive contre la
résistance albanaise principal objectif
la reprise de cette route reliant la
capitale pristina à pec dans l'ouest de
la province
ce soir ils contrôleraient une grande
partie de cet axe stratégique pour les
policiers serbes qui dispose d'armements
lourds et de 30000 oms est
incontestablement un succès majeur mais
enfin les combattants de lui ces cas qui
se battent pour l'indépendance de leur
province ne s'avouent pas vaincus s'ils
sont moins nombreux et moins organisés
que les serbes
ils ont deux gros avantage sur leurs
ennemis d'abord leur parfaite
connaissance de cette zone montagneuse
ensuite le soutien croissant de la
population car à chaque nouvelle attaque
serbe à chaque fois qu'un autre village
brûle les albanais n'ont d'autre choix
que de fuir
et c'est sur ces routes de l'exode que
s'aiguisent
chaque jour un peu plus
le ressentiment anti serbes et leur
désir d'indépendance les élections
législatives au cambodge se sont
déroulées hier dans un calme relatif
mais les résultats tardent à venir pas
avant la fin de la semaine normalement
pour l'instant on imagine assez mal que
le parti au pouvoir pour gouverner seul
pourra donc une nouvelle fois tenter une
alliance entre les frères ennemis qui se
sont déjà déchiré toutes ces dernières
années une transition douce maintenant
pour le football français l'adjoint
d'aimé jacquet roger lemerre va prendre
en charge l'équipe de france championne
du monde avec déjà un objectif la
qualifier pour le prochain championnat
d'europe christelle bertrand laluque
bachelot s'est passée la coupe comme on
passe un relais roger lemerre est nommé
sélectionneur pour que la prochaine fois
ils fassent encore gagner la france
l'annnonce de sa sélection n'était un
secret pour personne
roger lemerre a donc la lourde tâche de
succéder à aimé jacquet l'adjoint
devient titulaire et ce n'est pas pour
ça qu'il va copier toutes les méthodes
de son prédécesseur
j'ai toujours été avec ses idées je
dirais je ne suis pas content je ne suis
pas pour mais je suis à côté de lui et
là on se rejoint
quand j'ai parlé de savoir faire
français d'écoles françaises
on est reconnu partout mais pas
forcément les entrepreneurs les joueurs
mais les joueurs sont issus de la
formation qu'ils ont reçue à partir de
là
je suis assez fier de pouvoir continuer
l'oeuvre en poids frisant les instances
fédérales ont mis plus de temps que
prévu pour faire leur choix
c'est finalement un entraîneur issu de
la fédération qui a remporté le plus de
suffrages
à 57 ans roger lemerre a toutes les
qualités pour inspirer confiance d'avoir
des missions
c'est un homme qui aime relever les
challenges et les défis ont certains le
propre affectif mais en fait c'est un
homme très déterminé déterminé comme
joueur professionnel est déterminant
comme entraîneur il commence en 1975
avec le red star puis lens le paris fc
strasbourg et l'espérance de tunis le
maire rejoint la fédération en 86 pour
s'occuper du bataillon de joinville et
en 95 gagne son premier titre de
champion du monde catégorie militaire
appelé en janvier 98 par aimé jacquet
lemerre devient champion du monde toutes
catégories première mission qualifier la
france pour leur donner
le maire a un contrat de deux ans
renouvelable suivant les résultats
il était dans l'ombre de jacques est
aujourd'hui il passe dans la lignée
l'île de houat en face de quiberon
bretagne vient d'accueillir une
quinzaine d'adolescents d'une cité de
gennevilliers en banlieue parisienne à
ses jours qui se voulait éducatif et pas
seulement consacré à la détente aux
sports garçons et filles ont étudié
là-bas le monde de la mer un sujet a
priori difficile mais qui les a
passionnés reportage vincent est végétal
vous allez le faire
ça n'est pas tout à fait une classe de
mer d'abord parce que l'école est finie
et ensuite parce que les uns et les
autres ont choisi de participer à ce
stage sur leur temps de vacances
abbas manger le planton on peut le péché
le plancton et s'en nourrir
ça veut dire que ça veut dire que quand
on boit une gorgée quand l'âge c'est à
dire que ça sauver des millions mais toi
tu te retrouves tout cela l'amérique est
en galère ça va tu peux survivre
même sans être en galère l'intérêt
suscité pour la vie marine
soudain deux se limite plus aux dauphins
et aux requins et lons enthousiasme pour
quelques au plancton aux allures de
micro aliens des océans
l'expérience est renouvelée plusieurs
années de suite avec ce qu'il souhaite
et c'est ce suivi dans le temps qui
fondent les espoirs de l'association
ardue qu'au bas et de l'enseignant
initiateur du projet je pense souvent
que les enfants dans l'avant dans le
laboratoire vont regarder l'écran dix
minutes un quart d'heure maximum
meilleur départ cette réticence
ouais ses cahiers et stylos et puis très
vite 10 passionne très vite 10 passionne
très vite ils posent des questions
simples mais toujours intéressantes et
ça c est moi c'est siri jouissent en
différentes couleurs je voudrais pas
d'éclair
ce laboratoire qui accueille les jeunes
s'intéressent aux phytoplancton pour ses
qualités cosmétique mais pas une
expérience de concentration le plancton
est le premier moyen d'achats
alimentaires et surtout c'est le poumon
de la planète c'est à dire qu'ils nous
fournissent plus de 70% de l'oxygène de
l'air que nous respirons
c'est donc bien ce bouillon de culture
marin qui nous permet de respirer
beaucoup plus que toutes les forêts du
monde respire et on plonge et c'est le
problème est quand la météo bretonne à
ses caprices
on doit se contenter d'une crique abrité
où l'on a pu apporter que les tubes à
nadia que l'on suit ici on appelait a
décidé de tout faire pour devenir
technicienne en biologie marine et ce
sont sans doute ces vocations naissantes
qui réchauffe le coeur du professeur il
en a bien besoin dans une eau à 16
degrés est en maillot de bain faut
d'avoir trouvé une combinaison à sa
taille et là on est sur le terrain c'est
à dire mon nez complètement sur le
terrain et c'est beaucoup plus agréable
d'une part et intéressant puis ça nous
passionne quoi c'est ça c'est que la
passion vient en touche en regardant à
l'école cet appareil est ce monde du
silence
si loin de la ville bruyante de la cité
aura été pour beaucoup d'entre eux leur
seule semaine de vacances dans notre
série les vacances des autres ce soir
l'italie est d'abord les états unis des
américains ne prennent que très peu de
vacances finalement par rapport à nous
autres européens et spécialement
français reportage filmé via son dans la
famille lahoud je demande la mère qui
part en vacances d'été dans quelques
instants
moi j'ai trois semaines maria peu près
la même chose n'est pas au même moment
on n'a qu'une semaine ensemble alors
tout le monde vient mes parents ma soeur
mon frère tous les enfants c'est super
chaque année la famille seront à ocean
city sorte de palavas locales à trois
heures de route de washington
il loue un appartement qui permet de
coucher huit adultes et trois enfants
il en coûte 900 dollars soit 5400 francs
par semaine chacun paie son écot on
retient l'appartement d'une année sur
l'autre pour être bien sûr d'avoir le
même et l'on fait très attention au
budget on va dépenser entre 12 et 15
cents dollars comprend la location et la
nourriture que nous avons apportées et
peut-être de repas au restaurant 9000
francs la semaine tout compris pour les
plaisirs de la plage c'est un budget
moyen
les baigneurs peuvent trouver beaucoup
moins cher à quelques kilomètres d'ici
dans les campings qui affiche complet
tous les week ends d'été
ici c'est une vingtaine de dollars par
jour 120 francs avec la nourriture la
semaine tout compris revient à moins de
5000 francs pour une dizaine de
personnes
certes on est libre aux états unis mais
pas égaux en droits face aux vacances
pas d'obligation pour les employeurs les
congés sont en général attribués à
l'ancienneté moyenne deux semaines par
an au début la première année on a une
semaine de congé cinq ans on a deux
semaines après dix ans et trois semaines
pour avoir trois semaines de congés il
faut travailler cinq ans tue environ 7
jours de vacances par an
mais on nature de congés mieux c'est
quelques jours c'est pas suffisant pour
décompresser
le phénomène est nouveau l'amérique
laborieuse veut maintenant souffler un
peu d'où est-ce que vous sentez coupable
avant c'était le cas mais là c'est la
deuxième année que je me sens pas
coupable j'ai 56 ans et j'apprends fin
faire plaisir même si ici on préfère ne
pas en parler à voix haute l'amérique
est bel et bien divisé il y a ceux qui
croient à la vertu du travail et les
autres de plus en plus nombreux qui
pensent aux bienfaits des vacances
plus proche de nous et de nos habitudes
les italiens les deux grandes stations
balnéaires italiennes sont rémy ni la
plus populaire et portofino la plus chic
contrairement aux français chez eux et
bien les italiens aiment beaucoup les
séjours à l'hôtel il ou très peu
reportage hunt chalon que l'on regarde à
droite que l'on regarde à gauche aussi
loin que porte le regard c'est le même
paysage un patchwork coloré de parasols
sur 100 km la riviera adriatique rimini
l'endroit favori des italiens en
vacances ils sont 3 millions à venir ici
chaque été surtout en août surtout entre
le 10 et le 20 quand les villes se sont
vidés c'est un individualiste forcené
que sont les italiens aiment être en
groupe i mean il adore les jeunes les
dragueurs style aldo maccione et bien
sûr les amoureux qui se croient seuls
mais comment font-ils
et surtout les familles où nous arrive
ici d'habitude avec sa famille il reste
d'habitude 10 un jour il retourne
presque est toujours dans le même hôtel
il connaît tout le monde il est connu
par tout le monde
il est connu par les propriétaires de
l'hôtel oui une des caractéristiques des
italiens 72% d'entre eux c'est de
choisir l'hôtel plus que tout autre mode
d'hébergement
rien qu à rimini et sa région il y en a
cinq mille 5000 et on y va en pension
complète depuis des années souvent trois
générations ensemble nous venons
assidûment depuis 1970 ici je me sens
comme à la maison avec même quelques
choses en place et les femmes d'habitude
font le ménage à la maison ici à l'hôtel
elles ne font rien le talent des
hôteliers de rimini
et de créer cette ambiance familiale de
personnaliser l'accueil de célébrer les
anniversaires de mélanger les clients de
fidéliser ainsi leur clientèle grâce
aussi à des prix très étudiés si c'est
un endroit où on mange bien et on ne
pense pas aux démos et environ 230 un
jour entre la pension complète le
parasol le transat et toutes les
distractions
on dépense ici en moyenne 350 francs par
jour et par personne et la vie tourne 24
heures sur 24 pour de plongée de nuit
pour les sportifs les plus grandes
boîtes de nuit d'europe dans les
environs de rimini
pour les mordus de danse tandis que les
gens plus âgés vivent des soirées plus
calme
ainsi vont les italiens rimini heureux
dans la foule
à l'opposé de la jet set qui préféra
décidément portofino de l'autre côté de
la péninsule
ici dès qu'un certain quota de visiteurs
est atteint on ferme la ville ici
l'hôtel le splendide l'un des plus beaux
palaces du monde coûte 3000 francs la
nuit mais riche ou pauvre
les italiens ont tous quelque chose en
commun les italiens n'aiment ouvriers m
lorsqu'ils vont en vacances ils aiment
vivre il aime s'amuser
elle aime se sentir en seigneur alors il
la mutalité des italiens qui lorsque
mamba 15 il préfère vivre une semaine
d'un senior et danse un jour comme une
esclave et à portofino comme à rimini le
sentiment d'être un seigneur c'est bien
sûr en soit on l'a pendant l'été les
festivals ne sont pas réservées aux
seuls lieux de vacances exemple lyon et
ses nuits de fourvière qui permettent le
lyonnais de voyager au travers de soirée
musicale hier soir louis carzou pascal
couillaud nos reporters ont assisté à la
soirée de musique celtique
lorsque les cornemuses du bagad de
quimperlé partent à l'assaut des
terrasses yonnaise l'on pourrait croire
que cette fois les bretons ont conquis
la capitale des gaules
mais il s'agit de conquête pacifique
orchestrée par les nuits de fourvière le
festival d'été de lyon pour sa cinquième
édition a choisi d'offrir le temps d'une
soirée le cadre de son théâtre romain
aux musiciens sel tout un symbole même
si les artistes aguerris du genre
préfère parler de résurgence plutôt que
de robin il est vrai résurgence sont pas
résurgence dont il ne faut pas
s'inquiéter parce que jamais je pense
que les celtes l'essai ce ne seront pas
des impérialismes seront jamais des gens
qui voudront conquérir la planète est
imposé et donc sceptique à toute la
planète
gay
j
à s'y rendre
et pour montrer qu'il n'a rien à envier
aux institutions bretonne le festival
lyonnais a même invité la jeune vague ou
200 avec les corses un quatuor familial
venu d'irlande dont les festivaliers ont
aussi apprécié les mélanges musicaux
fait de pop rock et de son traditionnel
du hollandais
vrai que l'on ressent en france
notamment grâce à la bretagne une forte
présence herti et je crois que c'est
aussi pour cela que le public français
est très chaleureux c'est réceptif à nos
balades
offrir au public resté entre saône et
rhône les joies de promenade musicale
d'un continent à l'autre
telle est l'une des recettes de ce jeune
festival et dans deux jours les nuits de
fourvière s'envoleront du côté de cuba
vous parliez tout à l'heure de dopage la
nouvelle est tombée pendant ce journal
elle ne touche pas ce dopage ne touche
pas que le cyclisme le sprinteur
américain dennis mitchell vient d'être
suspendue sine aidiez par la fédération
internationale d'athlétisme pour s'être
dopé il a été contrôlé positif lors d'un
entraînement c'était au mois d'avril
dernier
même sanction pour rendre dit barnes qui
est détenteur du record du monde et
champion olympique du poids les deux
athlètes américains ont été pour
l'instant suspendu donc à peine les
principaux titres de l'actualité d'abord
l'épopée du tour de france qui a repris
tout de même ses droits dans les alpes
aujourd'hui plus froid et brouillard
victoire maillot jaune pour l'italien
pantani une sérieuse défaillances pour
jan ullrich et puis le directeur sportif
et le médecin de l'équipe hollandaise
tvm transféré à reims le juge
d'instruction pourraient les mettre en
examen ce soir ce n'est pas fait pour la
voilà dans un instant les prévisions
météo il avait le martinet je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
chaîne au revoir
oh